[Applause]
that's amazing does that happen like in
target like okay you just walk in and
you're like well thank you I ride that's
always yes and everything yeah we're
both on Texas you recently were in Texas
again right yeah you don't live there
anymore right no I have a house there
for you know if I want to go see family
and stuff because they still do but I've
slowly moved my family out here so it's
working clever like yeah I just for some
reason I wanted to go back to my middle
school I wanted to go back to my
childhood home which I do often and oh
yeah that was me bothering the class and
I got to just be there and say you know
like I was here and I never ever thought
that I could be where I am now on yeah
it was just really neat to see and my
teachers remembered me and one of them
just ripped to me she was like I
remember she was like I'm gonna go do
this movie I was like yeah right she
just wanted to lie and get out of school
that was I went back to my school my
ever my algebra teacher missed over um
was like who are you gonna how are you
gonna know what they're doing with your
money if you're gonna make all this
money when your allows like I'll pay
some want to do it and I hope they don't
screw me over I was like and then I saw
her and I was like still hoping I got it
out but you went to your childhood home
is that kind of special for you like
yeah it was so well I try to go there
often just because it's it's nostalgic
for me and I've gone every year so well
there's me and but I grew up there
everything started from there so I
actually got to knock on the door and
someone was finally there because no
one's over there no it's just chill dude
and he's like yeah come look around he
was so unfazed that I was there he's
like yeah parently you wrote on this
wall he goes also there's a crib in the
the garage if you wanted I what my crib
he was like yeah I was like my crib is
in your garage she goes man I was like
can I have it you're sure I'd like yours
all this stuff and I had written in the
closets that I was in love with Cole
Sprouse
I am older than you who is that bowl
Sprouse was on Suite Life of Zack and
Cody
okay I know that yes with that show and
I thought we were gonna be together one
day
then I guest-starred on the show but I
kissed his brother and I didn't get to
kiss cause I feel bad for you I hate
acting like I I don't know how you do
that like it we just want to where their
mouth is have been oh my god your first
kiss was with a stranger and an actor
that's you know what mine wasn't acting
it wasn't Cameron mine was horrible it
was like he was searching for something
with his talk there's nothing in there
it's just my mouth like and then I
literally went and spit in his bathroom
it was horrible you said that this album
is your most honest album so why do you
think so because I started so young
there's a huge part of me that didn't
get a chance to develop my identity in a
normal setting so when I was working
with Disney it was the best time of my
life and I had a great time I have
nothing but good things to say but it
was a bit more controlled there were
certain things that I was you know kind
of had to do and not maybe go into like
figuring out what my sound would be so I
I've constantly been trying to make my
music better and better because you know
I I know that people may not think I'm
the greatest singer but I just worked my
ass off and I love I really love writing
and creating and creating melodies and
growing and I felt like this was my
chance to say all the things that I
wanted to say and in that way which was
talking about relationships and talking
about difficult times or being
vulnerable or being stuck in your head
because you know I can do that a lot and
but I wanted it to feel good you know I
wanted it to feel like every word
mattered and you could feel it
physically and I'm still in the studio
actually now because I've I feel like
it's inspired me and I just want to keep
going ahead of time yeah and that
you making out that always happens with
me - I make an album and then I'm all
and then after I'm releasing like right
while I'm doing and I'm doing another
way I exact it always happened something
like I don't know but I want to point
something out because doing the voice
especially it has been really
interesting because a lot of people
always think cuz you said oh I know
people might not say the best singer the
best singer in the world talking to
everyone in the world right now it's not
the loudest and it's not the you know oh
my god you've just sing like Whitney
Houston every time we get the best
singers in the world move you and and
that comes from all different sounds and
styles so like from a singer to a singer
it's beautiful what you do and I love
your record and I I love big huge songs
but I love singing your music it means
something and it moves people so don't
ever negate your gift because it's
powerful I was in a car and I was losing
Spotify or something and I was like what
and I knew it was you cuz I got all your
music but but I was but I was like what
is it this whole idea like as a writer
myself what a concept that nobody's ever
done like I mean why did that it did
that word just stick out for you yeah I
felt like you know that song actually
came into fruition four years ago so Wow
it's stuck with me throughout creating
this album because I like the kind of
song that says look I'm not perfect
you know but I do know that I deserve
I'm special though yeah and I think that
is so it's such an important thing to
say it's like I need that
you know I've compared myself to people
for years and I feel like I'm you know
sometimes get insecure and I get you
know I go through normal things and it's
just that word means so much to me
because that's exactly what it means it
means that every single person wasn't
meant to be like everybody else kind of
like you're saying to me I guess I'm now
saying it back to myself but it's a it's
true you know you are each created to be
who you are meant to be and that's that
you know and I think until you believe
that you are rare no one else will yeah
and that's what I love about it's like
an empowerment anthem like I love I love
it like I told you in the room it takes
a lot to get me on a treadmill
and I'm like I gotta have a good record
and I've been jamming the orbit just
non-stop so it's it's a really great but
you also have a new beauty line and it's
called rare beauty yeah but you what got
you into the beauty world first off I
have such a connection with my fans and
most of the time it's talking about real
things that they're experiencing and
when I wanted to do this thing I wanted
to actually create a lifestyle with it I
wanted a line that was that was simple
and that was hyper allergenic and and
thank you that's light on animals
nothing it I wanted it to feel like
every girl can wear it or whoever wants
to wear it but also build coverage so
it's simple stuff to help you just know
how to do the go to things and it's
beautiful and it's encouraging I have
you know I have so many ideas for it to
come where it just can be something
powerful or people can feel good yeah it
is nice because I didn't grow up knowing
how to do makeup there's a lot of girls
that aren't we were all like tomboys and
did you do that so yeah this is really
great easy and and you have such a huge
fan base of women to like and I love
that you're not just about the
aesthetics you're also about what's
inside the mounts and that's super
important um something super random I
hear true or false you're a fan of shark
tank yes I am true I am that's very true
yeah how did you get in I know a lot of
people it's like you either love shark
tank or no or you've never seen it oh no
once you want you're in not to one
episode you're never gonna go back I'm
just so all of a sudden I think I'm them
I'm like royalties that's a good one
like I just try to like shine in as if I
knew anything but I realized I've like
owned half the things that were you guys
probably owned half the things they've
created because I just don't know it I
don't exactly it's been around for so
long that I have the sponge I got the
comfy I got them you're like oh my god I
have that
that I need that yeah for summary so
your your other thing is which is funny
because if our showed today but you
another obsession is true crime you love
like you love true crime so much you
went to something I didn't even know
existed yes which is crime common yet do
they do it a crime con okay so they give
us a real case and this glass yeah so
they this case in particular has been
reopened you're getting to see the
interviews and the interrogation pages
from 20 years ago now we're interviewing
the same people we it's not my case but
it's like I was I was literally just
pleading ganda but it was it was really
interesting like from going in to see
how they I mean but I'm gonna be honest
I'm not good at it I was like everybody
did it that's what I said I was like no
no he did it and then they would say
somewhere stuff I was like mmm they both
did it I was like everyone exactly
because I was if you get jury duty don't
show them exactly
hi everyone did it interested to it's
just a interesting subject yeah
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going